[Applause]
good afternoon the industrialist and
Colombian Leo silver established the
Gabriel silver lecture in honor of his
father shortly after the conclusion of
the Second World War his goal was to
promote the cause of peace and he
believed that bringing world leaders to
our campus for discussions about
international affairs would advance this
project in 1950 general dwight d
eisenhower then president of columbia
university delivered the inaugural
gabriel silver lecture general
eisenhower spoke about a subject that he
was uniquely qualified to explain namely
the obstacles to building and preserving
a peaceful global society in the wake of
World War two he called for many things
in his speech but chief among them was
the rejection of what he called quote
the policies and prejudices which bulk
this free exchange blocked the free
exchange of ideas between nations of
information and knowledge that will make
human living a more full expression of
man's dignity Eisenhower properly
understood that respect for knowledge
and the sharing of information is
essential for democracy and a necessary
foundation of a tolerant society
according to Columbia's president that
at the time constraining such expression
would have the effect of undermining
global peace and prosperity and spawning
ignorant and distrust nearly seventy
years later his words resonate loudly so
much of what we are focused on here at
Columbia
so much we're focused on but a project
that I know consumes the interest of the
World Bank is supporting our research
and scholarship the new wave of
collective global actions sufficient to
meet the many different problems facing
humanity this requires a substantial
proliferation of partnerships between
universities and governments and NGOs
and the world institutions such as the
World Bank Columbia School of
International and public affairs has a
proud history of engaging in precisely
this type of partnership and endeavor
and the work they have pioneered at
Columbia will now become much more
common across the breadth of the
University as the result of a new effort
we have launched this last spring in
this fall called Columbia World projects
a feature of this initiative will be to
devise productive and practical
collaborations capable of producing
measurable change with partners beyond
academia partners such as the World Bank
in a moment the Dean of the School of
International Public Affairs Mara Gino
will formally introduce our guest dr.
Jim Kim for now I simply want to say
that dr. Kim is a fitting person to
continue the tradition begun by Dwight
Eisenhower at the middle of the 20th
century and carried forward by an August
group of former Gabriel silver lecturers
including George Marshall Madeleine
Albright Stephen Breyer and Ban ki-moon
I know dr. Kim to possess the expansive
skills needed to succeed at the upper
echelons of higher education and also as
the role of a global policy maker he has
demonstrated these capacities is a
formidable advocate for addressing
global health concerns
and now as head of the World Bank where
he has made the ending of extreme
poverty the organisation's overarching
goal we are really honored Jim to have
you with us today before I conclude I
want to thank Michelle Fleury for
moderating the question and answer
period following dr. Kim's talk I also
want to recognize the marraige I know
for all she has accomplished as Dean of
the School of International Public
Affairs the school is thriving so many
ways under Dean jános leadership
sefa has launched new initiatives in
cybersecurity central banking and
financial policy and social
entrepreneurship and she also
contributes significantly to SEPA and
the university through her own expertise
in international trade and investment
policy thank you and please now welcome
Dean Mary Jane
[Applause]
good morning Thank You president
Bollinger Columbia University has never
been stronger and it's really your
leadership that's been the driving force
for Columbia's global vision and the
relevance and success of this great
institution it's a privilege for me to
serve as dean of SEPA I see friends
colleagues and students thank you for
joining us for the 2017
Gabriel Silver Memorial Lecture which
the School of International and public
affairs is delighted to host in
collaboration with the world leaders
forum as noted the silver lectures
cephas most prestigious lecture
established in 1950 to foster
international understanding on critical
global challenges we've been fortunate
to have had extraordinary leaders to
deliver the silver lecture president
Bollinger alluded to Dwight Eisenhower
when he was president of the university
Rajiv Gandhi as Prime Minister of India
and most recently ban ki-moon during his
final months as secretary-general and
today we continue this very important
tradition by welcoming to Columbia
University dr. Jim Kim president of the
World Bank Group in its more than 70
years of operation the bank and its
partner agencies have played an
essential role supporting economic
advancement and addressing defining
problems facing humanity and while we
know the bank was originally founded in
the aftermath of the World War two to
support rebuilding of countries riven by
war it has continually redefined its
mission to evolve and ensure its
relevance and its ability to meet the
needs of global populations and
countries worldwide in the early part of
its history it focused on infrastructure
investment around the world
later on loans and technical assistance
and then prioritize poverty alleviation
and more its impact has been immense
and the world has made progress its
recent projections by the World Bank
suggest that for the first time in human
history the number of people living in
extreme poverty has fallen below 10% of
the global population for our part sefa
is devoted to much of the same core
mission of the bank more than half of
our students today are studying
international trade finance and
development sustainability in the
environment other areas critical to the
bank we have numerous faculty that
continue to serve or have served in
senior positions at the bank are one of
our most popular degree programs is a
collaboration with the World Bank since
1992 our students regularly work with
the bank's teams on capstone projects
including six just last spring on
extension of educational services in
Malaysia assessing digital technology
and communications infrastructure in
Malawi promoting open data and Tanzania
with more than 230 SEPA alumni either
currently or formerly part of the World
Bank system dr. Kim I say to you your
visit today's of deep significance to
the school in our community and I'm very
grateful that you have chosen our
University to deliver this major address
in advance of the upcoming Bank Fund
meetings dr. Kim brings unique
attributes to his leadership of the
World Bank a former University President
as a scientist and doctor dr. Kim joined
the World Bank Group in July 2012 and
soon after he assumed his position he
established two ambitious goals to guide
his work to end extreme poverty by 2030
and to boost shared prosperity focusing
on the bottom 40 percent of the
population in developing countries in
September last year
the World Bank Group board unanimously
reappointed him to a second five-year
term and already during his first term
the World Bank Group supported the
development priorities of countries at
levels never seen outside of a financial
crisis and with its partners achieved
successive record replenishment of World
Bank Fund for the poorest the
institution also launched several
innovative financial instruments
including facilities to address
infrastructure needs prevent pandemics
help millions of people forces
forcefully displaced by climate shocks
conflict violence and also to support
Financial Inclusion before joining the
World Bank Group dr. Kim a physician and
anthropologists served as president of
Dartmouth College and held
professorships at Harvard Medical School
and the Harvard School of Public Health
from 2003 to 5 he was director of the
World Health Organisation's hiv-aids
department where he led the 3x5
initiative the first ever global goal
for AIDS treatment to expand access to
antiretroviral medication in developing
countries in 1987 he co-founded the
Partners in Health a nonprofit
organization that works in poor
communities on four continents he has
received numerous awards and today he
delivers the silver lecture and an
important moment for the bank just days
before its annual meeting in Washington
next week and indeed at a significant
period in the world a time of rising
tension immense humanitarian crisis and
when globalization itself has come under
strain we look forward to his views
today on the many challenges facing the
world and how the bank will continue to
engage the future in areas critical to
human progress and the global economy
following his presentation dr. Kim has
graciously agreed to take quest
from our audience in a discussion
moderated by Michelle Fleury New York
business correspondent for the BBC
without further delay please join me in
welcoming dr. Kim to deliver his remarks
thank you so much Dean J now and I'm
especially glad to be here with my old
friend Lee Bollinger you know in 2009
when I became president of Dartmouth
College I went to my first Ivy League
presidents meeting and I think it was
here in New York Lee and I was thinking
oh my god we get to go and with these
eminent scholars people like Lee
Bollinger we're gonna sit down and talk
about the most important problems of the
day we're going to discuss higher
education and its role in the world we
talked the whole time about football and
we talked about football because that's
it's a league it's a sports league and
where you set the academic index lower
border determines whether you win or not
and Lee has done so much for this school
but I think he may be remembered for
Columbia being three-and-oh in their
football team and leading the Ivy League
with Dartmouth right now but I just it's
great to be here at Lee's been here for
15 years you know being university
president is one of the most difficult
jobs that I can imagine having had the
experience for a relatively short period
of time but I I want to pay tribute to
Lee and all he's done in so many
different fields in the defense of
affirmative action the defense of
diversity you know he's a great man and
I'm honored to be here with him thank
you
so today the the crisis and Dean Jay now
I think talked about it a little bit
it seems that commitments to human
solidarity are breaking down
we have nationalism we have isolationism
revolting against trade agreements there
are so many forces in the world that
seem to say you know we don't really
want to embrace the rest of the world
what we're going to focus on is what's
in it for us and so I think that the
most important thing that we have to do
in the World Bank Group but also
especially in universities in places
like Columbia is to rebuild the
foundations of human solidarity and so
after having worked on trying to build
human solidarity around the issues of
health and education for most of my life
we come to a moment now when when we
have to ask ourselves the question how
do we rebuild these foundations now I
also want to let you know that this is
an absolutely urgent task everywhere I
go I see images just like this where
young people are on broadband they're
looking at their smartphones and more
and more and this is going to be
complete very soon everyone in the world
no matter how poor knows how everyone
else lives and it's a real phenomenon
it's we call it the reference income and
this is research that we've done at the
World Bank Group the more access you
have to the Internet the more your
reference income goes up in other words
the income to which you compare your own
goes up so what we found is that when
when you start seeing how well other
people are living you have higher
aspirations higher ambition and there
are a lot of good effects but the other
thing that we see is if your aspirations
start to rise but then there is no
opportunity it can lead to fragility
conflict violence I mean so much of what
happened during the Arab Spring was a
result of people getting at having a
college education but being unemployed
in Tunisia the highest rates of
unemployment during that time were among
college educated young people over 50%
unemployment so this is the crash course
we're going down this is that this is
the collision that we we're seeing high
aspirations lower opportunities and and
the need to invest more in people
now this talk in in so many ways and I
beg your indulgence on this it took me
my whole life to prepare for it and so
I'm gonna get a little bit biographical
because it's hard to understand where
I'm coming from
without telling you a little bit about
where I came from so this is me and it
was about in 1962 or 1963 I was born in
Korea
not too long after the Korean War and as
you can see I was pretty well fed back
then I was well taken care of and my
parents through really freakish good
fortune had actually met and married in
New York City right here my mother was a
student at Union Theological Seminary my
father was a dental student studying at
NYU and they met in New York City
married here my older brother was born
here and then they went back to Korea to
try to make their lives but what
happened to them is something that
happened to very very few Koreans by
being here by being in New York City
their aspirations were raised and of
course their aspirations for us were
raised and so I had had the great
opportunity then to come back to the
United States when I was about five
years old and live out the rest of my
life as an American back then though the
World Bank which as Dean Jo described
came out of the ashes of World War two
and was founded to rebuild Europe wasn't
very let's say didn't have very high
aspirations for Korea and and what they
said it's probably hard for you to meet
let me read it for you Korea would find
it difficult without foreign aid to
provided its people with more than the
bare necessities of life
so Korea didn't qualify for a world bank
loan because it was so poor until I was
about 3 years old 1962 and the
relationship between the World Bank
Group in Korea the long history of the
of the relationship between the World
Bank Group and Korea has really had a
profound impact on me and how I lead the
institution in a bunch of different ways
so first of all the World Bank had said
very negative things about Korea's
prospects just look at the country in
1959 the year I was born most of the
natural resources mineral wealth was in
the northern half of the country north
of the 38th parallel the industrial park
of the peninsula was also in the
northern part the southern part of the
peninsula was the agricultural part
literacy levels were below 20% in the
early 1960s
so no industrial base no natural
resources agricultural low levels of
literacy now back then right about at
that time some of the explanations for
Korea's inability to develop were
focused on Confucianism they said you
know Korea has a fundamentalist form of
Confucianism and because of that they
will never be allowed they will never be
able to grow and then probably 20 years
later the development economists at the
time said you know it's Korea's
commitment to Confucianism that has
allowed them to grow so it it it it
helped me to gain a healthy skepticism
about the the pronouncements of
especially development economists in
thinking about the prospects for
different countries and so now one thing
I tell everybody is that in the World
Bank Group of today there's no such
thing as lost causes there's no country
that we're going to get out of because
we think there's no hope in this case
hope is not the result of analysis but
hope and belief and optimism has to be a
moral choice every single country should
be able to rise out of the ashes just
like Korea the other thing though is
that the second project that Korea
received World Bank funding for was
education and the World Bank was very
much against it right they were very
much against Korea investing in
education in just its second loan and at
the time there was a very strong sense
that the World Bank Group that what you
do is you invest in infrastructure in
other words get rich first and once you
get rich then you can invest in your
people but the Koreans rejected that
idea you know it was really pretty
pretty stark there was a there was a
gentleman named Robert garner a very
respected World Bank development
economists who later was the first
president of our private sector group
IFC and in in a trip to Colombia and
Colombia had presented a
for its development that balanced
infrastructure investment with with
human capital investments with
investments in health and education and
his response to that proposal he said
and I quote damn it
we can't go messing around with
education and health we're a bank
now this persisted for a very long time
and I would argue that in many ways it
persists up to today now thinking about
all these different issues and in and in
in the process of moving to the United
States I had the great good fortune of
having a father who was very practical
he's a dentist and my mother studied at
Union Theological Seminary she was a
philosopher she eventually did a PhD in
philosophy in in in fact studied
Confucianism those two influences were
very powerful in my life but I was
leaning far more toward my mother's way
of approaching the world in my father's
and so one day I was I did my
undergraduate work at Brown University
and one day I flew home after the
semester and my father picked me up at
the airport we were living in Iowa at
the time so he picked me up and we're
driving on this rural road back home and
he asked me said this was my sophomore
year he said so Jim what are you
thinking of majoring in and I told him
dad I'm gonna major in politic political
science and philosophy and I'm gonna
lead a social movement someday so my
father the dentist slowly pulled the car
over to the side of the road and he said
he said look after you finish your
residency you can study anything you
want now not you laughs but when I tell
this story to an audience of Asian
American older people they don't laugh
at all because it's like of course
that's the right thing to do it turns
out I'm very grateful to him for having
done that but what I did was I sort of
went around his admonitions I went to
medical school and at the same time I
did a PhD and this is the campus of
Harvard where I did both my degrees and
at the time I felt like the task for me
was to bring these two together bring
medicine together with the study of
anthropology and anthropology you know
we study all the great thinkers
marx and engels at the time you know
Pierre Bourdieu was was the was the sort
of hot French thinker of the time and we
studied all these different views of how
to move the world
toward one in which there was more human
solidarity more equality opportunities
for everyone there are many different
views and in fact when I was in graduate
school there were strongly competing
views there was one view that said that
planned economies that trade with each
other and and work for equality of
outcomes is the right approach and there
was another approach that was saying all
of us have to deal with the market
system and in studying these different
approaches to how society should be
organized one of the things that struck
me and this was in teaching the
introductory anthropology course as a
graduate student one of the things that
struck me is that the the drive toward
human solidarity is deeply embedded in
our in in you know I don't want to say
genes but it's deeply embedded in the
way that we have evolved as human beings
I remember stories that we were telling
about about the bones of of ancient
peoples I mean tens of thousands of
years prior where you could tell that
there was an older gentleman who had a
handicap his entire life and so
literally would have had to be carried
around by his family and the tribe and
so this the sense that human solidarity
was at the core of what allowed us to
survive all these years as a species was
core now at that time you know for me I
remember graduate school it's just like
an idyllic experience where I could
spend a whole day reading a book and
sitting in cafeterias talking to people
but eventually as I finished I asked
myself the question so what do I do
what what is what is my responsibility
and what can I do to bring these grand
ideas together with practical solutions
and so I met these two people Paul
Farmer and Ophelia Dahl and we started
this group called Partners in Health and
by the way the film is opening tonight
it's playing somewhere
in in in the theatres in New York City
starting tomorrow and we founded this
organization with the idea that we were
going to provide health care to the
poorest people in the world and we were
going to do it on the basis of a
philosophy and the philosophy that we
adopted came from liberation theologians
and many of those ideas were were
crafted you know in this neighborhood
liberation theologians and we called it
a preferential option for the poor and
for us it was a preferential option for
the poor in health care and we felt that
it was a much more powerful idea than
the others that we'd been studying you
know in 1978 the World Health
Organization came out with this notion
of health for all by the year 2000
but it it was a great slogan they did
lots of things to sort of get the idea
out but there wasn't a plan associated
with it so what we said was we're going
to take seriously this idea that came
from mostly Catholic priests in in in in
Latin America and the idea was that
you'd live and work with the poorest of
the poor and then learn from them what
they need learned from them what their
aspirations are and then do everything
you can you could to help them meet
their aspirations so we started in Haiti
and we asked ourselves so if you're
going to make a preferential option for
the poor in a place like Haiti what what
you know what would we do and when we
asked them if you were if you were to
talk to people who were in the field
that it wasn't global health back then
it was international health if you were
to ask them what they would what they
should what we should do they would say
oh gosh Haiti so poor you should only do
the very minimum the basics you should
only do the things that are
cost-effective you should only do
vaccinations and gee you know other
things just aren't possible but when we
asked the Haitians what they want they
wanted every child to be in school they
wanted to be able to produce their own
food
and they wanted a hospital so that's
what we did we we built a bakery we we
built a hospital
we built schools and we began the
process of making ourselves humble in
front of the ass
operations of the poorest people now the
second place that we worked in a large
scale was Peru and this is the part of
the project that I took most
responsibility for and and we were going
to do the same thing it's a it's an
urban squatter settlement it's on the
one hand it's it looks very poor because
it's a squadra settlement but if you can
see there are electric poles so the the
level of poverty was nowhere near the
level of poverty in rural Haiti there
was no electricity at that time in rural
Haiti but then something happened that
really challenged us fundamentally we
saw patients like this this is milky
Addis actually now one of the stars of
the of the movie that was made about
Partners in Health
Melquiades was suffering from multi
drug-resistant tuberculosis this is a
form of tuberculosis that's resistant to
the two most powerful drugs and so the
official position at the time of the
World Health Organization of the Pan
American Health Organization of just
about every public health leader was
that you do not treat multi
drug-resistant tuberculosis in poor
countries it's they said it was too
expensive it distracted attention from
treating regular tuberculosis the the
drug regimens were too complicated and
and they were we're talking about a
minimum of 18 months of treatment and
during that 18 months of treatment at
least 12 months where these patients get
an injectable an intramuscular injection
six days a week for about twelve months
so incredibly complicated when these
cases come in to the hospital here and
my my old teacher Lee Goldman is here
you know the place place goes crazy
because you have to put them in a
negative airflow room to prevent them
from infecting anyone else really hard
to treat the side effects of the
medicines are are severe and so this was
a fundamental challenge for us how
serious were we oh yeah preferential
option for the poor what about those
patients are you going to treat those
patients we felt we had no choice and so
we began and what we found was that by
using community health workers and
visiting patients every day we got
higher cure rates than any Hospital in
the United States and it turned out that
what was the most important element was
seeing these patients every day
providing the level of tender loving
care by nurses by community health
workers that got them through this
difficult treatment
this is Melquiades a couple of years ago
I met Milky Hadas in Lima when we had
our annual meetings down there and I
just couldn't believe it
I mean this guy looked like he was
almost dead very close to dying and he's
now a confident young man and actually a
bit of a movie star in Peru because he's
in he's in this film then AIDS so I
remember 1982 when I started medical
school that we were just beginning to
learn about HIV and it was so
frightening and from 1981 when it was
first described until 1996 it was
hopeless everyone was dying from it but
in 1996 highly active antiretroviral
therapy really completely transformed
the disease except for poor people and
so as we saw the discussion around HIV
treatment in poor countries it was just
this intense sense of deja vu oh my god
they're doing it again it's exactly the
same thing all over again they're saying
it's just not possible it's too
expensive it's not cost-effective you
shouldn't do it and in fact when the
administrator of the US Agency for
International Development in the early
2000s
testified before Congress here's what he
said if you've traveled a rural Africa
you know this people do not know what
watches and clocks are they do not use
Western means for telling time they use
the Sun these drugs have to be
administered during a certain sequence
of time during the day and when you say
take it at ten o'clock people will say
what do you mean by ten o'clock so that
gentleman had visited Africa some time
before that and the African colleagues
that we knew said you know the only one
who was late to every meeting was this
guy right now but let me this is andrew
noxious and Renacci os-- is a very good
man right I don't mean to make fun of
him he's a very good man and he was only
saying what just about everyone else in
the world
was saying people who are my heroes were
saying you know HIV treatment in Africa
I think we're really talking about the
next generation my heroes were saying
that and they were of tiny tiny few
literally a handful of global public
health people who at that time were in
favor of trying to treat HIV in Africa
but in Haiti we were seeing patients
like this this is joseph jun
unfortunately passed away some time ago
but we were seeing patients like this
and at this time famously the world
bank's position was that antiretroviral
treatment should not be offered and and
they and the World Bank actually forbid
countries from using World Bank loans
for treating HIV but was not cost
effective it couldn't be done at scale
it was not sustainable over and over and
over again so think about what everyone
was saying everyone was saying 25
million people in Africa living with HIV
I'm sorry they're all dead because it's
just inconvenient it's just too
expensive and we kept saying a small
group of us especially in Haiti we kept
saying that patients like this can get
better they're not a different form of
human being these medicines will work
with everybody and we began treating and
we began making the argument that if we
allow this to happen if we allow 25
million people to die because of our
inability to get around this fact that
it's complicated and difficult to treat
HIV we will be guilty of a passive
genocide and we our generation will
always be remembered as the generation
that allowed 25 million people to die
so we began treating and results were
fantastic
we used to call it the Lazarus effect of
HIV treatment now I made the point about
mr. nachos because again he's a very
good man who cares a lot about
development and about the poor but what
we've learned is that these things
happen because people don't always think
even powerful people they don't they
don't think and make decisions on the
basis of rationality and evidence I wish
they did but they don't we actually did
a World Development Report a few years
ago and calling it we called it Minds
in behavior and the conclusions were
that people think automatically they
tend to fill in missing information and
think quickly people tend to think
socially they are very much affected by
what the people around them think and
they think according to mental models
and so the social thinking and the
mental model that existed at that time
was it's just impossible and it was
difficult for people to look forward and
say what our future generation is gonna
say about us if we let all 25 million
people living with HIV die there were
heroes in this fight and one of them the
most unexpected hero is George Bush and
everyone around him his own head of
USAID was saying they can't do this
because they don't they don't they can't
tell time but he vetoed all their
decisions and said we're gonna do this
and he launched the President's
Emergency Plan for AIDS relief probably
the single intervention that's had the
biggest impact on Africa in many many
decades so he going against the
conventional wisdom made a big
difference in other was just your own
Jeff Sachs one of my heroes Jeff Jeff
was the only one the only one among the
economists who actually came to Haiti
and saw that this was possible and then
fought and fought and fought for more
financing more funding for HIV he taught
us them one of the most important
lessons he said you know you guys gotta
stop talking about the M word and start
talking about the B word not millions
but billions of dollars and for us in
global health who had nothing we
couldn't get our heads around it but
Jeff helped us and he is still fighting
the good fight today but he was
absolutely critical in winning this
battle so now there's a lot more
financing this is how much money you
know it's it's sort of exploded now in
terms of money for for global health but
the lesson from this graph is that it's
probably going to tail off for a little
while especially given the nature of the
global economy and it's not nearly
enough it's not nearly enough to meet
the aspirations of people today now in
the in the mid 90s late 90s and into the
2000s at a period when most of the my
time had been spent five
against the World Bank Group I got so
exasperated that with with colleagues we
wrote this entire book critiquing the
World Bank Group it was called dying for
growth global inequality in the health
of the poor and it was essentially a
500-page extremely well-researched
critique of the World Bank Group and I
was part of a movement at that time
called 50 years is enough in which we
tried to close the bank and the IMF on
his fiftieth anniversary this 1994 so we
lost that battle which was which is good
and we lost that battle and what
happened at around 1995 was that the
World Bank began to change very quickly
based on evidence and I have to tell you
this is the thing I'm most proud of
being president of the World Bank Group
is that this is an organization that
will respond to evidence that will
change as it needs to and now I have the
great privilege of being president well
let me tell you how that happened so I
was president of Dartmouth minding my
own business when I get a call from
Timothy Geithner and Timothy Geithner
was Secretary of Treasury he was also
Dartmouth class of 83 and when Tim
called me and Lee knows this story well
it's usually because he has a friend
with a kid who wants to get into
Dartmouth
I had my piece of paper I was ready to
write down the name of the person that
Tim was recommending but he called man
he said instead hey how would you like
to be president the World Bank and I
said you mean the World Bank he said
what do I need to do so we'll come down
and talk to President Obama I said when
he said how about tomorrow so literally
the next day I fly down to talk to
President Obama walk in the office and
it's quite an experience walking into
the Oval Office
especially with President Obama and that
voice of his and he said to me he said
so Jim why should I nominate you to be
President of the World Bank I mean what
am I going to tell people and this is
exactly what he said what do I tell
people like Ernesto Zedillo
Ernesto's a wonderful man former
president of Mexico a great development
economist he said what am I going to
tell people like Ernesto Zedillo that I
chose a physician and an anthropologist
and not a macro economist to be
President the World Bank and I said to
him I said well President Obama have you
ever you have you ever read your
mother's PhD dissertation
he looked and he said well yes I have so
I after seeing him speak in 2004 I
researched him and I found out that his
mother had done a PhD in anthropology at
University of Hawaii so I actually
ordered her dissertation from the
University of Michigan archives that's
probably like one of five people who had
ever ordered her dissertation and I read
the whole thing and I said well
President Obama you'll remember that
that when your mother went to Indonesia
she studied the artisanal industry and
it was specifically artists who worked
in metal the the the the metal the metal
focused things and if you've seen these
beautiful Indonesian about works of art
made out of scrap metal and she showed
that while every economist suggested
that these artisanal industries would be
wiped out because of globalization she
showed that in fact they thrived that
globalization was great and I said you
know that's that's what you'll get from
me I'm not gonna be able to give you the
view of the world from 30,000 feet like
macroeconomists do but I've been on the
ground for 25 years and I'll tell you
how our programs are working there and
he looked at me and he said you know I
get that now later at a at a more social
event around with other people sitting
around a table he said you know Jim that
was one of the best ploys to get a job
I've ever seen read read the president's
mother's thesis so so you may be
thinking you're eating arcane pieces of
work but you never know how it might
come in handy now at the World Bank
Group two goals in poverty boost shared
prosperity and we get to those two goals
in three different ways the first is by
boosting economic growth I'll tell you
I'll tell you how we're trying to do
that inclusive sustainable meaning
meaning environmentally sustainable
economic growth the two is investing in
human beings and I love that see pose
hashtag is hashtag invest in people I
think I saw that on the chart invest in
people and the third is to create
resilience to the to the major crises of
the time climate change refugees
pandemics now
this is a difficult part of the lecture
because it it's it's a conversation with
many of you who may have participated in
the Occupy movement how many
participated in the Occupy movement so
many of my friends and certainly my
friends children participate in the
Occupy movement but since the days when
we were studying Marx and Engels and
looking at these two ways of organizing
the world planned economies versus
market economies this is what happened
President Xi Jinping at Davos just this
year in January said this whether you
like it or not the global economy is the
big ocean you cannot escape from any
attempt to cut off the flow of capital
technologies products industries and
people between economies and channel the
waters in the ocean back into isolated
lakes and creeks is simply not possible
so the head of the largest Communist
Party in the world is telling us that
the global market system is the thing we
cannot avoid and so the task is to
figure out how we can make the system
work for everybody if it is the ocean
then we need to equip everyone to be
able to swim in it and that's what
they're trying to do of course in in in
in China now we worked very closely with
the Chinese government and I thought I
thought that this was such an important
statement and it really defines what I
do now every day now this was occupy and
and I I think the the the the commitment
of the Occupy movement was very
compelling the idea is that we are the
99% in the financial system doesn't work
for us but what I have learned probably
the most important thing I've learned in
my five years as a head of the World
Bank is that finance is such a powerful
tool and it is our responsibility to
make finance work for everybody
professor Bob Shiller Nobel laureate
economist from Yale wrote a book called
finance and the good Society and if you
haven't read it I recommend it it didn't
sell very well he told me but he really
points out and I quote finance despite
its flaws and excesses is a force that
can potentially help us create a better
more prosperous more equitable Society
we
have the potential to support the
greater goals of good societies
prosperous and free societies in the
industrialized as well as the developing
world if we expand correct and realign
finance now this is a picture of the
Ghanaian stock exchange and I have
learned about these financial financial
tools and it's just incredible how
powerful they are these are the tools
that just down the road and Wall Street
just down the road and all the great
financial industry that sits right here
in New York City these are the tools
that people use every single day to make
themselves wealthier and we're now doing
everything we can to use those same
tools to support the poor there there
are great examples of how to do it now
in terms of using the tools of the rich
to serve the poor there are some facts
that have created a situation of just
enormous opportunity 78 trillion dollars
is the size of the global economy
there's more than 10 trillion dollars
sitting in negative interest rate bonds
in other words you you give your money
to the Japanese central bank and they
don't pay you interest you pay them to
hold your money ten trillion dollars
negative in to see you give them money
but you pay them to keep it another 24
trillion or so in very low yielding
government bonds and again this is
because people are worried people are
scared of the risk they would take and
putting their money in anything else and
another 8 trillion sitting in cash
these are usually thousand euro bills
just sitting in people safes now
everybody who owns this capital wants to
get more out of it they want they want a
better return and we think that the
opportunities in developing countries to
get a better return if we play our role
in de-risking and making these
investments possible are just enormous
we have a fund called the Global
Financing facility for every dollar that
a donor gives us we can give the country
five four five six dollars of not grant
based money but money that they can pay
over twenty or thirty years at 0%
interest so getting five times the money
that you can pay back over 20 years at
0% interest often makes much more sense
than getting grants so leverage
something that rich people do every day
is something that now we're trying to
use much more for the sake of the poor
I'll never forget the Ebola outbreak I
mean I think most non physicians
especially non-infectious the disease
physicians have probably forgotten about
it but I will never forget how terrified
we were during Ebola but what happened
was we waited way too long the epidemic
started in December of 2013
money didn't start flowing until
September of 2014 nine months later and
so we decided that we're never gonna let
that happen again and what we did was we
created something we call the pandemic
emergency facility this is an insurance
instrument that will disperse
automatically when a problem happens so
this is the these of the number of cases
that happened during the Ebola outbreak
right and this is when the month the
money started to flow was about in here
right right the money really didn't flow
till out in here if the pandemic
facility had been in place back then we
would have dispersed some cash right
here at the beginning and probably
snuffed it out but certainly the
automatic part of the insurance bond
instrument would have happened here and
we would have had a much better chance
of stopping it now this is a completely
new financial instrument nobody had
thought about insuring the poor against
pandemics before but we did it and in
June I actually did the bond call I was
in the call talking to the different
investors 450 million dollars and we
paid eight point seven percent interest
and the eight point seven percent
interest was enough for investors to
take the risk they could lose all their
money they could lose all their money
but it was worth the risk because we
paid eight point seven percent this is
what rich people do every day they share
their own risk with the capital markets
we haven't been doing it enough for the
poor we are talking about a human
capital project because we're living in
the middle of a human capital crisis
this is a map about childhood stunting
how that stunting is one of the things
that worries me most in the
childís taunting means that your two
standard deviations below height for age
in in in the first two years but also
all the way through five years two
standard deviations below height for age
what we found is that these children end
up actually having 40% less brain mass
the mass of their brains is actually 40%
lower and we've done Studies on stunted
children they they don't learn as well
and they don't earn as well and so what
is the percentage well overall 155
million children in Indonesia 37 percent
of their children are stunted Pakistan
45 percent of their children are stunted
Ethiopia Democratic Republic of the
Congo 50 percent of their children are
stunted these these children when they
grow up to be adults will not be able to
compete in the global economy but it's
not just it's not just childhood
stunting that that we have to tackle
from the early to the very early in a
child's life there's other things 250
million children in the world cannot
read or write
despite some schooling in Kenya Tanzania
and Uganda three-quarters of third
graders and these are children who've
been in school up to third grade
three-quarters of third graders in the
Democratic Republic of the Congo cannot
read a single word so not only do we
have a problem with stunting we have a
problem with education what we've
learned it's it may be hard to say that
what you're seeing is the top of the of
the graph is the number of years of
schooling the dark blue is a number of
years of learning adjusted years of
school in other words are they actually
getting the learning that they're
getting from the number of years are
sitting in those seats and what you see
is huge variability and you can there
are countries in which they may be in
school for 10 years but it's the
equivalent of less than five now we have
a plan for this we we just released a
World Development Report on education
they're very specific things that we
want countries to do but this is a major
crisis now what about technology this is
the one of the coolest things I've ever
seen I visited Rwanda and Rwanda is the
first country in the world to use drones
to
life-saving blood so instead of having
to create the supply chain to take blood
everywhere it's needed the use drones
and entirely based on automate
artificial intelligence fantastic
innovation but we think the actual
impact of automation is going to be
mostly to get rid of jobs jobs are going
to be lost lots and lots of low-skilled
jobs will be lost because tasks are
going to be done by machines we may be
able to get ahead of it but not if we
not unless we start running really
quickly our teams now are really looking
at human capital differently and we're
going to publish soon a look or a
document that's called the changing
wealth of nations and here's what we
found so the dark blue is human capital
the lighter blue is produced capital
meaning you know factories and things
that you build that can that can
contribute to productive capacity and
the gray is natural capital the forests
you know the natural resources energy
resources and what we found is that
human capital is so much more important
as part of the overall wealth of nations
than we'd ever thought in fact but in
fact not until very recently have we
included an accounting of human capital
now some of you may say why you keep
saying human capital they're human
beings man there's a reason why I'm
using the term human capital because in
order to make a change you can have to
get the real decision makers who are
usually the heads of state but also the
ministers of finance you're gonna have
to get the ministers of finance
especially to think about investing in
human beings differently
so human capital is huge now this is
huge this is overall wealth this is
natural produced and human capital per
capita so you can see the high income
countries of a huge amount of wealth per
capita and I'll and the majority of it
is human capital the middle-income
countries have a lot less at look at the
low income countries this is how much
the low income countries have to catch
up in terms of human capital if they
want to compete in the digital economy
now
the question then is how do we change
the environment so that heads of state
and ministers of finance are cannot but
help to invest more in human beings what
do we need to do well one of the things
we need to do is to convince them that
investing in human beings is directly
connected to economic growth and so we
begun work with the Institute for Health
metrics and evaluation in Seattle with
Chris Murray it was a who's a very good
friend of mine we did internship and
residency together and Chris started
looking using very sophisticated data
and analytic tools if you take the
average years of completed schooling
schooling if you take the average
standardized test scores for math
reading and science and then you take
physical and mental health in the
working age population if you take those
three things and ask a pretty
straightforward question if you divide
it up the if you divided up countries
into quartiles into four segments and
you looked at the group that improved
their human capital the most over the
last 25 years and you compare it to the
group who improved their human capital
the least over the last 25 years the
difference in economic growth between
the highest improvers and lowest
improvers is 1.25 percent of GDP per
year so you take that and multiply that
over 25 years this is extraordinary and
this is among the highest correlations
it's not causation it's right now we're
just we're running regressions and
looking at the correlation but this is
among the highest correlations to
economic growth that we've ever seen so
we have no choice now but to do this
calculation put rankings together and
reveal to countries how important it is
for them to invest in people now how do
you do that how do you actually make
things happen well Franklin Delano
Roosevelt is famous for having said to
labor leaders I hear you I like your
ideas now go out there and make me do it
in other words create an environment
where I have no choice but to do what
you want me to do a friend of mine
this is the president of the of the
European Commission jean-claude Juncker
jean-claude Uecker in 2007 during the
during the the financial crisis he was
prime minister of Luxembourg at that
time he's very funny man he said hey we
all know what to do but we don't know
how to get reelected after we do it so
how do we create a situation where we
forced them to do the right thing but
then also maybe even help them to get
reelected what what is the process of
doing it well
one of my one of my great mentors and
Lee Lee Goldman knows and Julie Richmond
he was he was the Surgeon General United
States he put he was the the creator of
I think one of the great programs of all
time which was Head Start and the way he
did Head Start was he had a knowledge
base that said do it he had a social
strategy and he had political will well
we need now to think about what it would
take to create equality of opportunity
we have to base this in a foundation of
human solidarity we have to have the
knowledge base and I showed you the
beginning pieces of it how important
human capital investments are we have to
have a social strategy how do we make it
so that the real decision makers will
make the right decision we have to
generate through that political will and
then we have to use financing strategies
as well can we create insurance
instruments that will happen
automatically can we use concessional
finance interest rate finance to compel
people to do the right thing
this is urgent aspirations on the rise
everywhere jobs being eliminated at huge
percentage this is a this is just our
estimate of how many currently existing
jobs will be eliminated by automation in
these countries and I you know this this
ranking of countries on human capital is
going to be incredibly contentious it's
going to be incredibly controversial but
I feel that I have a moral
responsibility to reveal this connection
and to rank the countries in order to
you know to do the right thing by the
hundred fifty five million children who
are living in poverty I think another
person who studied in this area
and and was one of my heroes had the
best way of thinking about urgency
around this kind of social action Martin
Luther King in his book letter from a
Birmingham jail now wrote about letters
that he received when he was in jail and
one was from a white moderate who told
him all Christians know that the colored
people will receive equal rights
eventually but it is possible that you
are in too great a religious hurry it's
taken Christianity almost two thousand
years to accomplish what it has the
teachings of Christ take time to come to
earth now I hope you see in this
statement the same thing that the people
who are against us treating MDR TB and
HIV were saying this is not a bad person
this is a person responding to the
conventional wisdom of his time to which
Martin Luther King responded such an
attitude stems from a tragic
misconception of time and a strangely
irrational notion that there's something
in the flow of time that will inevitably
cure all ills actually time itself is
neutral it can be used destructively or
constructively more and more I feel that
the people of ill-will have used time
much more effectively than the people of
goodwill we will have to repent in this
generation not merely for the hateful
words and actions of the bad people but
for the appalling silence of the good
people we cannot be guilty of being
silent about the crisis of human capital
investments but we have to be strategic
and we have to find a way to create a
situation where there's no choice but to
invest right now the situation in many
developing countries is well if you give
us money yes and preferably grant money
for health and education we'll do
something but if you don't we won't the
levels of investment are just nowhere
near what they should be and so we've
got to create an environment that makes
it impossible not to do it look when
Martin Luther King talks about repent
repenting my mother was a theologian and
I think it's okay to repent every once
in a while it's good it's good practice
to repent every once in a while but
better than repenting and especially I
see so many students in the room better
than repenting is to
what are the things that we're either
doing or not doing today that in 20
years will shake our heads and say how
can you believe that that's what we were
thinking can you believe that that's
what they were saying the white
moderates the head of USAID find out
what those things are take them on and
we have then a chance to create a world
in which every child has an opportunity
to become whatever they want just like I
did coming here from Korea and just like
I know all of you will as well thanks
very much
thank you
now we have about half an hour left so
we're hoping to get as many questions
from the audience in as possible when we
do eventually go round there are going
to be microphones people hand you a
microphone we'll ask you to introduce
yourselves and to say what's called your
from and just to give everyone a second
or two to sort of think up the questions
they might want to ask dr. Kim thank you
very much that's all for speech if I
could just pick up on what you said
there at the end the idea of launching
this ranking the importance of of taking
action now I mean that sounds like quite
a radical idea Wow
why the sort of new thinking now so I
mentioned it briefly but well what we
learned from Chris Murray out in the
Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation is that and I don't I don't
even actually know what this is and I
know students here know what it is but
the ability to use bayesian methods it's
a new kind of ability to crunch large
numbers much more effectively have given
him so much clearer view of what are the
causes of death its global burden of
disease report and if we apply that to
not only health outcomes but also
educational outcomes we're gonna find
powerful connections and powerful
connections to things like economic
growth that we wouldn't have been able
to do so
things have changed we've got a lot more
data now on health outcomes and
educational outcomes and what Chris
tells me is that and I have to give
credit to my predecessor Bob Zoellick
Bob really pushed on data transparency
the amount of transparency in the world
is just so much greater than it ever was
before that countries are sharing their
data and then the question is you know
do you have enough data and and good
enough methods so that you can be pretty
confident in making this connection
between health education and growth and
if you've got enough confidence are you
willing to withstand the clear criticism
and anger that's going to come from
countries that come out lower than where
they think they should come out so it's
it's very predictable we have a measure
called doing business
and it's not it's not a perfect measure
by any stretch but it's the only thing
where we look at the ease of doing
business in different developing
countries and in the reaction is usually
pretty predictable those who come out
high they like it and they use it
those who come out low critique our
methodology so we have we're working so
that the methodology is so robust that
we'll be able to defend it and keep
going and the other thing we're going to
do is we're not just going to say oh you
guys are in bad shape for every single
country we're gonna work very hard to
give them a plan for how they can much
more effectively and quickly improve
their stock of human capital so draw
attention to the issue and sort of use
public pressure to try and divert well
there'll be public pressure and I'm sure
that opposition parties will use this
you know in their own political interest
but what that will do is for the first
time create a political cost to not
investing in health and education and
often that doesn't exist the other thing
is I think investors are going to look
hard at at these rankings and make
decisions on where they invest their
dollars based on it and so in a country
a foreign direct investment goes down
what happens often is that your
borrowing costs go up and that gets
everybody's attention right and so
that's not what we're not trying to hurt
countries we're trying to reveal to them
the reality of their situation and and
and the urgency of the task of investing
in people you know I've been doing this
work on global health for 30 years and
I've spent 30 years begging for more
financing and I the notion that we could
take it from a purely supply driven
where it's just all about the generosity
of donors - one in which we have more
generous donors because they know how
important it is I mean we need to keep
pushing donors to provide more financing
but link that to demand where leaders
are saying oh my god we've got to get it
we've got to go up these ranks as having
a real impact on our political fortunes
on our economic fortunes if we can
create a situation like that then I
think we have a much better chance of
reaching this situation where everyone
has equal opportunity
those who are watching online or in the
room here please feel free to use the
hashtag invest in people to sort of
comment and share your thoughts and if
we could start taking questions from the
floor I see the lady there in the third
row in the blue shirt hello my name is
Amna buta I'm a Fulbright Scholar from
Pakistan as an aspiring policy maker for
Pakistan are pertinent to fourth
Industrial Revolution my question is
that currently with the recent creation
of Asian Development Bank how the World
Bank and the Asian Development Bank sort
of separate away from the competitive
environment that they were operating in
initially and how they can sort of
connect together to learn from the World
Bank's experience and sort of meet their
collective objective of development in
the world thank you thanks for your
question I think you mean the Asian
infrastructure investment bank Asian
Development Bank's been around for a
while and the new player is the Asian
infrastructure investment bank well we
we work very closely with them and you
know the one that one thing we have to
remember is that there's nowhere near
enough resources for infrastructure in
developing countries so we've welcomed
them from the very beginning in fact
there are HR systems there are financing
systems we provided them with all of
that and right now at a time when they
have very few employees what they're
mostly doing is Co investing with us and
so we'll prepare a project we'll put all
the pieces together and they just put
their money on the table another quickly
getting capacity and they'll be making
their own loans but you know what what
we've realized and over the past five
years what I've really worked hard on is
bringing bringing all the multilateral
Development Bank's together because we
have to work together we have to work
together as a single system and we're
closer to that I think now than we've
ever been you know we're talking the the
sustainable development goals are gonna
cost if we're gonna get to their goals
by 2030 four trillion dollars a year so
you put all the multilateral
thanks together we don't touch that
we're not even close so we have to work
together not only to make our own
dollars go as far as possible but we
need to use our dollars to bring in all
that cash I told you about that sitting
in these negative interest rate accounts
we've got to bring that off the
sidelines and put it to work for the
poor hi dr. Kim my name is Benjamin when
I am from a United Nations Development
Programme I recently professor Scott
Rosa I'll argue that 63 percent of
Chinese rural children have not seen one
day of high school education and this
conclusion actually stirred much debate
on the Internet community in China so
many people think we should focus more
more on the software construction for
example education rather than the
hardware for example infrastructure so
how do you envision the bank enhancing
its corporation based developing
countries in Africa and China and other
countries in China are in Asia and we
would there be opportunities to
establish relevant initiatives ways for
example the e IIb or other authorities
thank you very much thank you
Benjamin thank you for the question so
what we're trying very hard to do is not
go in a direction of either-or right
either you invest in people or you
invest in the drivers of economic growth
like energy and transport things like
that China's actually done quite well in
terms of its human capital investments
there the childhood stunting rates are
around 8 or 9 percent so you just
compare that to some of the other
countries you know Indonesia 37 Pakistan
45 India 38 China's run 8% now the
educational outcomes are mixed I mean in
Shanghai they're among the highest in
the world but in the rural areas they're
not they're not as good and so I think
for every country they're gonna have to
step back and say okay in addition to
investing in infrastructure in addition
to investing in all these other
important parts of economic development
we now also know that human capital is
far more important as a driver of
economic growth than we ever thought and
with every passing year as automation
becomes more sophisticated
our jobs are lost every passing year is
going to make human capital more
important right so in that context I
think we have to think differently I
think the notion that we bring in
private sector financing for more
infrastructure will free up money in
government budgets to invest in health
and education that's where we think
we're going to be going with many many
countries but the point is every single
country has to have its own plan and
there's no there's not going to be a
one-size-fits-all solution for everybody
and do you see bringing in the private
sector as part of it absolutely
absolutely so you know there we're now
working on on principles for private
sector involved in health and education
because it's not straightforward it's
not building more hospitals but what we
found is that in countries like India
more than half of all health services in
India are provided by private
practitioners so if you want to improve
the health care system in India you
cannot ignore the private sector you
have to figure out how to make it work
we think that as as jobs in light
manufacturing in agriculture as they get
eliminated probably the biggest growth
is going to be in empathy workers you
know the community health workers
community social workers community
education workers and I think that the
movement is going to be more in creating
cadres of individuals who can provide
those services and I think it's
perfectly reasonable to think that that
small and medium enterprise is run by
women for example could be one of the
ways of bringing those workers online
thank you for your lecture President Kim
my name is Mario Saraiva
I'm from CIPA I'm part of the Masters in
development practice and I have a it's
been a question I've been pondering
throughout my year at Seba first is what
does invest in human capital looks like
if you could please expand in that and
then should we make it profitable to
invest in human capital or in other
words should create an environment as
you mentioned that forces us our forces
policymakers to invest in Macau
but then if we do so can the world
really change if we're still acting
because of financial returns well the
the first the the the first part of the
question what does it look like so let
me just let me take exactly what it
looks like and we're trying to create an
example of just what it might look like
starting with a pregnant woman
and so in Rwanda President Kagame has
said that they're stunting level is 38%
he wants to bring it to zero in like
five years right never been done before
that kind of shift but you could do it I
mean based on 30 years of work in
developing countries if you had
community health workers out everywhere
identifying all pregnant women making
sure they have outstanding prenatal care
and this is not rocket science it's very
straightforward make sure that they have
attended births make sure that children
are given appropriate nutrition and
stimulation or the child development
from the very beginning improve the
quality of the primary school so that
they get preschool and they start in
preschool and then they go all the way
and every step of the way you're
improving the quality of the educational
system so that their learning outcomes
are getting better then when they get to
be 18 or 21 or whatever and going
through college then I think you've done
everything you can to give that the
pregnant woman and her child every that
the city you know as as good an
opportunities you can possibly imagine
for that particular situation now on the
profit motive you know I just refer you
back to the quote of President Xi
Jinping right so China when it shifted
from just simply dictating quality of
outcome to letting market forces work
you know it used to be that went out in
the 1980s Chinese young people could
quote from the little red book from now
and now most people quote she don't
shopping who said to get rich is
glorious who said things like some of us
will get rich first and in comparing
planned economies versus market systems
said I don't care if the cat is black or
white as long as he catches
mice and so it I I don't for me it's not
an ideological issue and you presented
it as you know how can this happen if
the ideology of profit I you know I was
trained by Lee Goldman alright so if you
guys don't know how what kind of figured
Lee is there's something called the
Goldman criteria look we all know I was
trained by Lee Goldman and what legal
been taught me was you got to go with
the evidence what does the evidence
suggest right the evidence suggests that
if you want to end extreme poverty you
need more economic growth evidence
suggests that if you want to end extreme
poverty you have to figure out how
countries can insert themselves in in
the global market system you know I I
met with the head of the Vietnamese
Communist Party right and he was a
highly respected man who has PhD in the
social sciences and his PhD was from the
Union of Soviet Socialist Republic
School of Social Sciences and his PhD
was in that well-known field of party
building party building right and I
asked him I said you know your
excellency how do you reconcile
Vietnamese socialism with your embrace
of the market system because all you
guys talk to me about is how you can you
can you can and you can interpolate with
a market system more effectively so it's
very simple he said you know we've read
our Marx - and every perfect socialist
system requires a stage of capitalism
right but he said something else that
was even more profound he said but we
realized that - perfect Vietnamese
socialism you needed faster economic
growth and more robust job creation so
that's why we do what we do and so here
was a person trained in the USSR in
party building the leader of the the
keeper of the faith of the Vietnamese
Socialist Party who was telling me hey
buddy have you seen the evidence the
evidence suggests that whether we like
it or not we have to find a way to
insert ourselves effectively because if
we don't it will be more poverty less
job creation less economic growth
hi dr. Kim my name is Gabriel barrientos
I am a second year student at SEPA
concentrated and development practice my
question is in regards to the
investments in education particularly we
see that a lot of developing countries
focus their investments on more
quantifiable things like infrastructure
building more schools or just getting
students into schools much like bolsa
família in brazil you just pointed out
that schooling does not equate to
learning how can investment models and
education shift into learning rather
than just schooling yeah so I strongly
suggest you take a look at our World
Development Report that came out just a
couple of weeks ago and some of that
some of the lessons from there or is
that you you first of all you've got to
be focused on learning and you've got to
be evidence-based and most school
systems are not like that the the great
movements around education have been
building schools and getting children to
sit in seats and get you know getting
their butts in seats as we say and we we
have a program at the bank called sub
air and I don't remember what said that
R stands for butts as in you know the
Spanish word for no very much focused on
on going from the quantity of classrooms
and the number of seats available to
actual learning so one you got to focus
on the evidence - it's got to be a
whole-of-government effort this is not
this cannot just be the education
ministry frankly education ministries
are often the weakest ministries in
developing countries and so what we're
trying to do with this human capital
index is to force countries not force so
we never force countries to do anything
but to make it possible for countries to
work with the minister finance you know
worried about his bond spreads and
worried about reducing FDI and have them
work directly with ministers of
Education and ministers of health there
are many many countries who are
investing money in health and education
getting nothing out of it so our our
laser focus over the next few years is
going to be to improve the quality of
those investments but in the world
Development Report we have a whole
program of how you can move more toward
learning and away from just you know
building classrooms
I'm guessing pretty much everybody in
this room has a smartphone we're all
used to access to the Internet I mean
how has technology well has it made life
harder or easier for you to fulfill your
mission well so the the the head of our
education practice now one of our most
brilliant economists worked for the
World Bank for many years and he was
asked to come back to Peru his home
country and take over the Ministry of
Finance but what he said to the
president was mmm now I want to be
Minister of Education because he knew
that he already knew then that better
educational outcomes were going to be
the most important drivers of growth for
Peru well he tells me is yes technology
can be very important but the biggest
problem for him was the ability of
principals to manage their institutions
and improve the quality of teaching over
time so he began focusing on literally
management skills to principals Jack Ma
that the founder that brilliant founder
of Alibaba in China is creating an
institute just to teach management
skills to principals so it's it's
potentially great I mean I think what
Saul Khan has done in the Khan Academy
that the learning modules are fantastic
you know in the Carnegie Mellon teaching
modules for chemistry math and physics
are just incredible right so I think
there's a lot of great stuff online but
at the end of the day it's going to be a
person intensive process you know
improving the quality of teachers and
the manager of teachers has to go side
by side with bringing technology into
the into the classroom and it's also
actually not Hardware it's the software
that goes on on on to the machines
that's going to make the biggest
difference we've actually translated
Khan Academy stuff into both Arabic and
Spanish to see if if the the impact that
has had in the United States can be
reproduced elsewhere thank you mr. Kim
I'm one from CIPA and from South Korea
and I have a question to ask you about
the woman's - initiative I mean the
woman entrepreneurs' finance initiative
that was a mischievously launched by the
World Bank in July please feel free to
correct me if I'm wrong but from what I
understand about how the initiative work
is the 1 billion financing that the
World Bank has will go down to
multilateral banks which will go down to
financial institutions which will
eventually go down to one more
entrepreneurs but some of the criticism
has been about how multilateral banks
will be able to arbitrarily define
women-owned banks I mean women-owned
businesses and be able to target the
women entrepreneurs that they want and
how does the World Bank intend to target
what you aptly call it the poorest of
the poor and especially considering the
fact that a lot of women entrepreneurs
in developing countries are engaging in
informal networks and I'm from markets
where they're not captured by the gut
state governments or formal institutions
and also if you don't mind could you
give us a update on the financing
because I'm from what I understand that
325 million was funded in August's and I
haven't seen an update since then so
that was a lot of questions a lot of
questions okay well I'm sorry but so let
me just so we started something strongly
supported by the Trump administration
but also any bunker Trump specifically
and it's actually built on our previous
experience we had something we did a
program called 10,000 women that we did
with Goldman Sachs where we so the great
thing about the World Bank Group is that
we have been in these developing
countries in the case of IFC the private
sector group for 60 years in the case of
the World Bank for more than 70 years so
we have incredible networks in all of
these different areas and the the idea
here and it's just getting started and
the number right now is over 350 million
and the 350 million of grant donations
will be leveraged with our own financing
- I think well over a billion we're not
quite sure how far it'll go but right
now there is a huge gap in financing for
women entrepreneurs part of it is
because it
and they the criteria for getting a loan
is often something that just can't be
overcome in many many developing
countries and so that's why we created
women a fun specifically focused on
women we will preferentially try to find
women entrepreneurs the 10,000 women
project has been tremendously successful
and because we have these networks we're
able to find women entrepreneurs now
you're right that in many countries a
lot of the women-owned businesses start
out informally now you know the the the
micro enterprise lending phenomenon has
done a lot to support informal
women-owned businesses but one of the
problems with micro enterprise lending
is that that very very few women who
started off getting these micro loans
turned their informal enterprises into
formal businesses that's why we're
focusing on entrepreneurship because we
want to identify those women who've done
well on an informal level and who are
already to create formal businesses now
it's just one part of what we do we also
have conditional cash transfers that go
directly to the poorest women but the
fact that we were able to raise three
hundred and fifty million dollars from
16 or 17 different countries in four
months was was was really encouraging
thank you very much my name is Catherine
I'm international student from Venezuela
here at Columbia University and my
question is regarding countries that are
facing a little political instability
for example Venezuela in the last few
years has reason the poverty rate has
risen from 40 percent to over 80 percent
and the humanitarian crisis is it's
really really precarious so how do you
be out or what's the base best way to
deal with countries in situations like
this with the political instability has
class such extreme rates of poverty yeah
so we're what we're not we're not
working in Venezuela right now and part
of it's because we would only work there
if the government asked for our support
and they haven't asked for our support
yet
are unfortunately fragility conflict
violence there are now 2 billion people
living in countries that are in some way
affected by fragility conflict and
violence so in our fund for the poorest
countries it's called Ida which is
seventy five billion dollars over over
three years we have doubled the the the
the amount of funds that are going to go
to fragile and fragile and conflict
affected countries we've been thinking
hard about this and we we as a World
Bank were not very involved in things
like refugee problems but Antonio
Guterres now the secretary-general of
the United Nations when he was the High
Commissioner for Refugees came to me and
said you guys have to get involved in
the refugee situation and I said why is
is because some of these situations last
for so long that we find ourselves a
bunch of lawyers doing development work
so we need to work together we need to
find a way to go upstream and stop these
things from happening so what we're
focused on right now is identifying sort
of pre fragile pre conflict countries
and intervene to see if we can prevent
this path down to fragility in conflict
one of the things we know investing in
human beings is critically part of it
and one of the things I worry most about
is there so many refugees and so many of
those refugee children are not getting
any education so they're in the time
that they're refugees we're investing
essentially nothing in in in their
education so the reason this is so
urgent and it's something that the
Germans understand very well I mean you
know during the German g20 which is just
you know it's still going on but that
the summit was in Hamburg in July
Chancellor Merkel at that time it was
the mr. finance Wolfgang schäuble uh
kept saying okay we we absorbed 1
million refugees from the Middle East in
North Africa but if we don't invest more
in in in sub-saharan Africa what we saw
over the last few years is nothing
compared to what will happen if if
people from Nigeria and Kenya start
getting on boats if Ethiopia falls apart
so the German leadership
for the g20 understood very carefully I
mean understood very well how important
prevention was right and so this is part
of that effort right we're we that the
prevention piece of it is investing in
human beings so that instead of being
frustrated by the lack of opportunity
that they're creating businesses that
they're you know becoming doctors and
lawyers and other kinds of things that
will it will improve the prospects for
everyone so not working in Venezuela
there's other countries we're not
working in Cuba not working in North
Korea a number of countries we're not
where we're not working yet but when
Myanmar opened up when Burma opened up
and there there are lots of issues there
now we were one of the first
organizations to go in and that's my my
hope is that once a very conflict
affected fragile country opens up we can
move in quickly to leave it there we are
out of time but thank you very much for
all of your questions of course you can
keep it
thank you and of course you can keep the
conversation going online the hashtag is
invest in people and with that that
brings to an end the 2017 Gabriel silver
Memorial Lecture thank you
[Applause]